[Music]
I saw those all over twitter and saw
that it was like sold out everywhere I
don't drink because I don't like the
taste of alcohol I don't like the
feeling being drunk and I'm horrified of
throwing up I drank a lot last night
forgetting that I was also gonna drink
this morning who doesn't like alcohol I
mean I I recently got turned on to
alcohol alright some of the BuzzFeed
post I like everybody was like this one
got me [ __ ] I lost my life I threw up
for five days everyone's like but it's
only thirteen point nine percent alcohol
so like how does that feel
people are saying that it's like and
like a four loko comparison you ever
tried what no do you ever hear it well
she's not yeah it's an energy drink four
loko is gross it's like very disgusting
like you know you're drinking gasoline
but if this tastes good then we're
getting into some scary territory this
smells like sangria like a nice brunch I
had last weekend look at the end like
obviously smells like college oh it's
it's dark yeah I think it is it's like a
syrup alright cheers cheers Cheers
here we go cheers cheers Cheers
I'm gonna try to get I barely taste the
alcohol in it it's still sweet it's so
good it's way better than four loko yeah
this look kind of thing they'll sneak up
on you later oh yeah it's like
reminiscent of childhood not the alcohol
but like it feels like it's like for fun
I definitely feel this already
I do feel the heat I feel I feel hot
I think maybe there's like a little bit
of fill device happening really I gotta
kill Akane I feel like they put in extra
citrus to hide their secrets the more I
drink it the more the alcohol comes out
and I know if it's all at the bottom
right now I was supposed to shake it
doesn't say you shake it shake it shake
shake
okay now I feel it do you feel the
hotness mhm
I actually want to take more sis with
this and that so I just thought right
this is how you get people into drinking
this is a great way alcohol the
packaging is beautiful
yes very few its I mean it actually kind
of matches my ensemble which i think is
saying something from just drinking a
couple glass like half glasses of
sangria I'm a lightweight kind of I had
one beer last night Mel's like whoo are
you doing it as somebody that like hates
alcohol it's actually definitely not the
worst alcohol I've ever tasted
I feel nothing and this is my second
glass
maybe it'll catch up to me in 15 minutes
I'm feeling it if you were to pregame a
night out like quick not expensive
meaning one bottle right I need is that
it'll do the job in in Duluth quick
exactly right you should probably wait
can we pause and act like we're fancy
wine connoisseurs in Napa yeah mm-hmm
mm-hmm
my palate is dancing yeah I have a
dancing palate it reminds me of
childhood on the rivers of the country I
cannot name mmm yes I think this is just
really showing that we are getting more
tipsy if we do this I think so yeah this
is really hitting me right now this is
the weird thing is it's like really
hitting me right now this isn't fake I
am actually like ready now I don't know
what the [ __ ] just happened
this is better than port like that it
does look classier boil up those four
logos weren't being in high school let
me really
[Music]
now we know I didn't told my boss I was
doing this feel like if I drank a bottle
of this I would instantly [ __ ] my pants
and cry oh my god college students do
not drink a follow this I just have a
very bad feeling don't do it don't take
the bottle you'll die that's written on
the back here it honestly says right
here
what is it Attorney General lightness
thought because I could feel that coming
on now alright you can feel it coming on
I lied ten dollars
I've been met on lunch yes great I'm
tipsy I'm not my life thanks there tape
it nine percent alcohols accurate with
ice I can see how somebody would get
this was fun I suspected I wasn't gonna
get anything else productive about today
about I feel like that it's true I
couldn't feel like I could go get some
production stuff done today but I got to
try it I'm glad I got to try to yeah
yeah and I will take the rest of it
alright well anyways Cheers
I like it it's good to be safe
you really finished that I'm scared for
you skinny man
[Music]